hey 42 here you would think of all those
furry hazard guards wandering around a
team of 24-hour security personnel and
her own private police force whose cars
are uniquely painted red by the way and
let us not forget her very own guard
corgis that it would be rather difficult
to break into the home of the world's
largest landowner and head of state of
sixteen countries shortly only a highly
trained secret agent could accomplish
such a feat nope this drunken fellow
managed it without any prior planning
not once but twice this paragon of
plundering is London born Michael Fagin
ironically he is the son of a champion
safe-breaker
but that wasn't what persuaded him to
try his hands at unlawfully entering
Buckingham Palace in interviews he
stated that he had no motive and he had
never even considered the break-in
before he had simply gotten drunk at a
local pub and was walking home past the
palace at 7 a.m. when he decided to go
for a stroll through the halls of
possibly the world's most famous
residence unemployed painter and
decorator Michael Fagin made his grand
break-in on July the 9th 1982 when he
was 33 years old after leaving the pub
the sprightly drunk managed to scale a
14 foot high wall at the rear of
Buckingham Palace his perimeter a wall
topped with barbed wire and revolving
spikes nonetheless I mean I struggled to
climb into bed at 7 a.m. after a night
in the pub so Fagin must have really
really wanted to get a glimpse of
Queenie to clamber over that he then
shimmied his way up a drainpipe on the
rear of the palace and entered through
an unlocked window Fagin then spent a
whole 15 minutes wandering the halls of
the palace without being seen one member
of the palaces domestic staff recalls
seeing him but after which she said she
didn't think he was sufficiently
suspicious enough to raise an alarm so
presumably one would have to be
outrageously suspicious before the staff
would actually do anything
according to Fagin after aimlessly
wandering the halls he found his way to
the Royal Apartments by quote-unquote
following the pictures on the walls I'm
not really sure what he means by that
but I can only imagine our owning
number of photos of corgis on the walls
as he closed in on the Royal Apartments
first he entered Charles's room but he
was not there Fagin did find half a
bottle of wine on the shelf which he
drunk in an interview Fagin later noted
that the wine was really cheap Fagin
then snuck into the Queen's bedroom
where he found her Majesty asleep Fagin
later noted that the bed was large but
she was definitely sleeping alone he
rips the curtains open and she
immediately awoke she sounded her night
alone for help but the maid in the next
room was vacuuming so neither she nor
anyone else on duty heard the Queen's
distress call so what did Her Majesty do
next well call the police of course I
just love to be the 999 operator taking
a call from the Queen well she didn't
actually call the police she called the
palace telephonist who called the police
for her of course so what did Fagin and
Her Majesty the Queen gets up to for
several awkward minutes while she was
waiting for the police to arrive
well she along with a footman actually
lured Fagin into the pantry with the
promise of free cigarettes in the glass
of whiskey the Queen and her foot man
kept
Fagin busy in the pantry with cigarettes
and whiskey until the police came and he
was arrested so what was Fagin's
punishment for his dastardly royal
intrusion at length a jail sentence was
he set upon by a pack of ravenous corgis
nope he got away completely scot-free
surprisingly at that time there were no
special laws in place that meant
breaking into Buckingham Palace was a
serious crime beyond normal trespassing
Fagin was let go without any charges
because on the UK law trespassing is not
a criminal offence but a civil wrong the
Queen could have taken him to court for
damages if she wanted to but could you
really imagine the Queen in court she's
far too busy deciding whether she'd like
her morning goblet made out of quail
eggs or duck eggs
the Queen is also exempt from having to
legally provide evidence unlike all
meager peasants Fagin was however
charged for stealing the bottle of wine
since
the only thing they had on him so why
the hell not but the theft charge was
dropped because the judge concluded that
Fagan was not mentally stable and
admitted him to spend six months in a
psychiatric hospital
it wasn't until 2007 when a new law was
introduced in the UK which made
trespassing unroyal or government-owned
property a criminal offense but this
wasn't Fagin's first expedition inside
the palace he actually broken a month
earlier - during his first visit he
didn't meet the Queen but he spent 10
minutes wandering the palaces vast
hallways staring at paintings
he then found his way to the throne room
and sat on the throne for a bit before
leaving the palace completely undetected
but these two Michael Fagan incidents
aren't the first time that Her Majesty's
private quarters have been penetrated in
2013 a burglar broke into the palace
after scaling a wall and kicking a door
down he made his way deep into the
palace but was swiftly arrested also in
1981 free German tourists camped in the
grounds of Buckingham Palace the entire
night mistaking it for Hyde Park Philip
I think there's some Germans in our
garden off with their hands
I mean heads folks are watching just
outside of Munich lies a sleepy village
called fuga right where the rent for a
whole year is just under 1 euro meat the
most audacious granddad's this side of a
Sunday roast the so called grandpa gang
pulled off the largest burglary in
English history